[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue ça vous regarde en
direct sur a dit de vous retrouver au
sommaire ce soir macron monte au front
il aura fallu attendre les trois
derniers jours de campagne pour que le
président de descendre enfin dans
l'arène le chef de l'état a pilonné
depuis le tarn jean luc mélenchon et
marine le pen renvoyer dos à dos dans le
camp des mirages des délits mensonge au
désordre mondial les extrêmes propose le
désordre français la charge est lourde
sera t elle suffisante pour nous
garantir une majorité forte et claire
comme il la réclame la réponse de nos
invités dans un instant dans notre grand
débat c'est un reportage exceptionnel
qu'est signé notre grand témoin ce soir
à la une de l'ops aujourd'hui une
fillette katia trois ans nous regarde
droit dans les yeux comme pour nous
demander pourquoi pourquoi chaque jour
depuis le début de la guerre en ukraine
deux enfants meurent le martyre des
innocents de boudhha c'est un récit
bouleversant sur l'enfance assassiné par
l'armée de poutine doan bui a mis des
mots sur l'indicible elle est avec nous
ce soir enfin nous retrouvons nos a
franchi pour leur parti pris ce soir le
carnet de campagne elsa monde un gamin
ce sera son dernier avant dimanche soir
une archive de brandon noir est sur ces
premiers ministres qui vont à la pêche
aux voix et puis delphine sabattier va
nous parler d'un livre coup de coeur qui
va vous faire aimer les maths vous
verrez pourquoi c'est réjouissant voilà
pour le menu c'est parti
[Musique]
et il sonne enfin la mobilisation
générale emmanuel macron aura attendu la
toute dernière minute de campagne pour
passer à l'offensive
on va revenir donc sur ce discours très
politique dans le tarn cet après midi
avec vous frédéric dabi bonsoir bonsoir
bienvenue sur ce plateau directeur
général opinion de l'ifop
votre institut qui a publié un sondage
il ya deux jours pour lci tf1 qui a pas
mal affoler les états majors en
particulier la majorité on va évidemment
en parler bonsoir carole barjon bonsoir
à vis de vous retrouver sur ce plateau
vous êtes éditorialiste politique et
grand reporter à l'ops bonsoir jean
philippe grelier merci d'être avec nous
constitutionnaliste et professeur de
droit public à l'université de lille et
dans un tout petit instant le
journaliste hayward routière journaliste
à l'express qui suit la majorité et
l'exécutif wallon joints dans un dans un
instant mais d'abord alors qu'est ce
qu'il a dit le président et pièces que
c'était à lui de faire campagne de la
sorte si j'ai bien compris stéphane
blakowski tout juste
[Musique]
si j'ai bien compris stéphane d'abord
bonsoir bonsoir il rythme et bonsoir à
tous périr à tout en fait alors qu
avez-vous compris du discours du
président semblait que le président
mâcon se trouvait dans la position du
lait du lièvre dans la fable où ça il a
laissé tellement d' avance à la tortue
sûr de gagner que maintenant à l'arrivée
et projeté il ya un doute il est un
crime qu au final c'est l'airé en fait
là et là comme un petit coup de stress à
la tortue d'ailleurs qu'il disait sada
s'agace la tortue s'agace chez les
scouts tortue saga
exactement ils revendiquent eux ce
surnom et de cette même en allant
doucement selon les derniers sondages le
frédéric peut-être qui affole le camp
présidentiel et ben
mélenchon pour avoir plus de voix que
macro au premier tour déjà salamé très
mal pour la majorité puis surtout il est
patient le président d'avoir une
majorité absolue au second tour donc
deux récents vous avez eu depuis
quelques jours on pilonne un petit peu
donc je vous ai fait une sélection des
snipers les plus prestigieux de la
majorité à tout seigneur tout honneur
gabriela taille qui traite mélenchon de
bourreau des contribuables soit bien
trouver je trouve le maire qui fait un
peu dans l'humour chavez golo alors
mélenchon en a accepté le comprenant ça
comme un compliment et puis plus
basiques et christophe castaner le
retour au monde soviétique selon lui
leur même hexabyte banksy est vraiment
pas du tout fan de polémique qui elle
aurait voulu convaincre les français
qu'elle prend vraiment des bonnes
mesures pour pouvoir d'achat quand le
dinan lisabeth maintenant tu tapes son
mélenchon alors elle tape sans mélenchon
moi je vois en face un projet de
division un projet qui vise à isoler
notre pays très anti européen et puis un
projet de taxation et d'interdiction à
tout va donc tout est organisé oui la
panique complète aujourd'hui d'en
convaincre aux taxations et
interdictions c'était des éléments de
langage qui avait déjà employé le
président quand il a donné une interview
à die journaux de la pqr il avait fait
le con tout on a fait le compte pour lui
vingt fois le mot taxation 30 fois le
mot interdiction dans le programme de
mélenchon enfin quand on est anti
libérale je pense que les taxes et les
interdictions ça ne voit pas affolé sont
ses électeurs à pierre fin de la
séquence et le président lui-même alors
qu'ils montent au front aujourd'hui
exactement la finale fini le président
réélu qui regardaient ça de loin
maintenant c'est le retour du président
candidat donc il a été dans le tarn pour
annoncer des renforts de gendarmes ont
fait près de nouveaux ceron ceron fort
avait été décidée au mois de janvier
mais là c'est l'occasion effectivement
de faire un vrai discours de campagne et
bien sûr une des premières phrases de ce
discours au milieu des gendarmes a été
consacré sans le nommer à un monsieur
qui avait insulté la police mais y ait
des choses que de là où je suis je ne
peux pas accepter
c'est qu'on insulte celles et ceux qui
risquent leur vie pour protéger les
nôtres
les applaudissements derrière
franchement tous les discours était axé
contre mélenchon alors justement c'est
ça la russie il n'a surtout pas un homme
et mélenchon ni le pen d'ailleurs mais
les a tous les deux mis dans le même sac
en disant qu'ils avaient quand même deux
gros points communs sur cette volonté
d'opposer les français donc pour
mélenchon on oppose les classes sociales
donc de riches pour les rn on
oppose d origine donc plutôt
d'immigrés si on si on veut puis
programme économique par ailleurs dix
ans toute façon c'est le extrême qui
font des promesses de milliards à
distribuer comme si l'argent tombé du
ciel bon ça c'était pour dézinguer un
peu l'adversaire et puis un moment quand
on est en campagne électorale il faut il
faut le dire aux gens s'il vous plaît
votez pour moi je veux pouvoir conduire
pour vous à vos côtés dans les années
qui viennent c'est la mise en oeuvre du
projet que j'ai défendue durant la
campagne présidentielle et qui nécessite
comme le commande nos institutions une
majorité forte et claire à l'assemblée
nationale c'est pourquoi on adressons
aujourd'hui je veux alerter aussi les
françaises et les français sur
l'importance du choix qu'ils ont devant
eux dès le 12 juin prochain si
l'élection du président de la république
est cruciale l'élection des députés est
décisif alors est ce que vous pensez
stéphane que cet appel sera entendu la
question qui tue est ce que le lièvre et
la tortue dans la fable fait pas une
fable aujourd'hui c'est pas possible à
mon sens parce que quand macron cherche
à dresser ce portrait très inquiétant de
mélenchon il a pu simplement là où ça
fait mal au regard des sondages
effectivement une majorité de français
trouvent que jean luc mélenchon a un
côté assez inquiète beaucoup plus en
tout cas que ceux qui trouvent que c'est
macron qui est inquiétant donc du coup
il ya une vraiment très grosse
accélération est ce que ça sera
suffisant pour être en tête au premier
tour je ne sais pas ce qui est sûr c'est
qu'au second tour a priori
bas par exemple la droite modérée si
c'est des duels nubes ensemble la droite
modérée ne va pas voter mélenchon en
tout cas par hervé morin ça c'est sûr il
est pour l'effacement de la dette
mais la dette voulait face et comment
vune face et en disant la banque
centrale européenne qui détient
l'essentiel de la dette française
et budget veut dire quoi ça veut dire
quoi dès qu'on sort de l'euro concret sa
monnaie et vous pensez qu'il ya des gens
qui vont prêter à la france si la france
dit je n'entre pas mal est donc là c'est
hervé morin j'aurais dû être françois
laon qui dit exactement la même chose
que le programme de mélenchon a
complètement irréalisable c'est juste
des incantations donc pour le premier
tour je sais pas si c'est y sera en tête
mélenchon de pour le second tour tandis
qu'avec la gauche et la droite modérée
ils réussissent vraiment avoir lui une
majorité et couture merci pour cet
éclairage des célestins absolument
carole barjon voté pour moi c'est simple
et c'est basique il était temps que le
président lui même si c'est vraiment à
la dernière minute descendre dans
l'arène pour ce message plein simple
porté par le chef de l'état dont la vème
république emmanuel macron voilà dont on
connaît voilà l'importance pour imprimer
oui le message même s'il n'est pas
d'après la constitution le chef de la
majorité n'entend on sait que tous les
présidents de la république se sont
engagés à la veille des législatives ils
ont absolument tout ce fait de gaulle
giscard verdun sur le doubs le bon choix
pour la france ça ça y ressemble un
petit peu
une stratégie tactique d'attendre au
fond la dernière minute pour que la
parole soit audible où il y avait le feu
au lac tout simplement je pense que
c'est les deux mon général
parce que à la fois frédéric ne dira
certainement encore mieux que moi tout à
l'heure les chiffres des sondages
montrent qu' il n'est pas tout à lille
est pas sûr d'avoir une majorité absolue
et qui est un risque pour lui de
majorité relative ce qui veut donc dire
qu'il serait contraint à ce moment-là de
négocier avec d'autres parties d'aller
chercher des voies pour pour faire voter
ses projets de loi ailleurs et macron
après tout
[Musique]
évidemment les pleins pouvoir enfin en
tout cas c'est ce qu'il a réclamé
aujourd'hui
donc ça c'est voilà il veut éviter la
majorité relative et c'est vrai que il a
perdu du temps
enfin il a perdu du temps moi je pense
que c'est un peu cynique et peut-être
même un peu un peu calculé parce que je
ne suis pas certaine que qu emmanuel
macron et jamais eu peur dray d'avoir la
majorité et qu'au fond
il avait pas il y avait quand même comme
vous le savez un très grand nombre de
semaines entre la présidentielle et
l'islam sont grands traits remet à
l'étude dont il a occupé le temps avec
la composition du gouvernement etc etc
mais il n'a pas un programme très précis
comme chacun a pu le constater et donc
au fond effectivement il a joué une
espèce de guerre d'usure et puis à la
fin il nous fait là la blitzkrieg des
stratégies de chloroforme voile
anesthésie au début puis on sort de la
boîte à la fin et la dramatisation parce
que là il a dramatisé aujourd'hui on va
le dire sur le fond bon soir à roanne
bruyckere vous travaillez à l'express
vous suivez d'exécutif d'accord avec
l'analyse tout ça finalement et finement
calculé
n'y a pas de panique alors je pense moi
peut-être pas emmanuel macron mais en
tout cas ses lieutenants ont joué un peu
à se faire peur au début et j'ai
l'impression que ces dernières semaines
on a on commence vraiment à avoir peur
d'une majorité relative c'est en tout
cas c'est ce qu'on sait ce qu'on nous
dit ça commence il quand même y avoir
une sorte d'anxiété qui monte pour ce
qui est de l'absence c'est quand même
assez assumer en tout cas en macro ni de
dire - on parle finalement moins ya deux
motifs pour l'opposition de critiques et
c est pareil au même pour l' annonce de
cette réforme de cet été c'est très très
abstrait donc si dimon dit pas tel
pourcentage pour l'indexation que ça on
empêche l'opposition 2
dans l'entre-deux tours entre la
présidentielle et législatives ça c'est
pas à risque de copains portant mais
pardon si on anime pas le débat
les gens se désintéressent voilà vous y
avait plein de gens plein de français
qui savent même pas
quelle est la date des élections
législatives quand même donc ça favorise
l'abstention est l'abstention elle
favorise macro c'est bon pour mac mahon
va essayer d'y voir plus clair dans un
instant sur les sur les sondages jean
philippe dauvin il a fait son verdun sur
le doubs
1978 valéry giscard d'estaing le
constitutionnaliste que vous êtes
considère au fond il est dans son rôle
le chef de l'état arrêtons l'hypocrisie
même président tous les français il fait
campagne pour son camp absolument et là
où il y avait une hypocrisie c'est
lorsque le message avait été transmis
aux membres du gouvernement d'ailleurs
de façon c'est exceptionnel parce que
c'était assez nouveau qu' il fallait
qu'ils aient un devoir de réserve jamais
entendu un devoir de réserve de la part
de responsables politiques ce sont des
responsables politiques ils ont besoin
d'une majorité pour gouverner qu'ils
aillent sur le terrain qu'ils se
retroussent les manches et qu'ils
demandent cette majorité le président la
république française effectivement est
le président de tous les français mais
il est dans une phase entre l'élection
présidentielle et les élections
législatives où il est à mi chemin entre
le président et le chef de la majorité
qu'il était pendant la campagne
présidentielle et le président qu'il est
en train de devenir ou de re devenir
puisque c'est la première fois depuis
1965 qu'on apprenne la république réélu
avec une même majorité à l'issue de son
premier mandat donc oui il est dans son
rôle il a besoin d'une majorité et et
bien il descend dans l'arène après ça
peut pas dire que je suis en désaccord
avec ce qui a été dit l'abstention
favorise macron elle favorise pas la
démocratie est le favori ce faire
l'adhésion ensuite aux projets qui
seront portés par macron mais
l'abstention favorise à court terme une
victoire de la majorité pro macron et
donc kim haussier de ne pas trop
intéressé les français est
potentiellement une une bonne chose si
on regarde un tout petit peu
rétrospectivement on a parlé de verdun
sur le doubs en 78 on peut regarder un
tout petit peu plus proche de nous 1986
françois mitterrand voit arriver à
grands pas la majorité relative pas
86,88 leur donner on voit arriver à
grands pas la majorité relative et à
cette phrase qui va être décisif
d'ailleurs il n'est pas bon qu'il y ait
une majorité absolue à l'assemblée
nationale
disant c'est moi qui l'ait demandé
je qu'un seul parti alors quand jean-luc
mélenchon dit ça on va l'écouter juste
en 2010 c'est la même chose est
quasiment la même question
qu'aujourd'hui c'est à dire qu'à la
veille du premier tour des élections
législatives on se demandait si la
réplique en marche allez avoir une
majorité absolue parce que il était
inconnu et voilà et au lendemain du
premier tour on se demande s il est
encore y avoir une opposition parce
qu'il y avait tellement fait un
raz-de-marée que voilà et je pense qu'on
s'achemine pas exactement dans les mêmes
proportions mais un petit peu vers ce
scénario l'encan beaucoup dans
l'opposition lui reproche d'avoir parlé
tel qu'il a fait comme jean luc
mélenchon va l'écouter
ce n'est pas au président de la
république de mener la campagne
législative que ses amis sont incapables
de mener le président de la république
vient d'être élu c'est au chef du
gouvernement
normalement de mener la politique de la
majorité parlementaire
c'est l'argument principal aujourd'hui
vous n'êtes pas d'accord
bien sûr il a raison sauf que le chef du
gouvernement
c'est le président la république en être
dans notre système le général de gaulle
disait
lorsqu'il était président la république
ne parlait pas du chef du gouvernement
lorsque vous désigner le premier
ministre le chef du gouvernement c'est
moi c'est moi qui dirige le gouvernement
c'est moi qui le composent c'est moi qui
vous ai nommé c'est moi qui vous ai fait
bon alors là où jean luc mélenchon a
aussi raison c'est qu effectivement ce
serait plutôt à isabelle borne et au
ministre de retrousser leurs manches et
d'aller sur terrain de faire vraiment là
la campagne de mener une à manifester
notable campagne met alors à roye
l'obtenir voilà
fidèles match commencé par là en disant
ça n'a pas grand sens et effectivement
qu'à un moment donné le président
applique les remplace ou en tout cas
s'introduisent dans la campagne dans le
débat parce que y'a un petit peu un vide
s'est pas vraiment surprenant
aucun doute c'est la parole
présidentielle qui est la plus audible
dans le pays et donc parler comme ça
vraiment à un ami ou un car si j'ose
dire c'est plus efficace oui clairement
oui alors c'est pas la seule parole aux
dites parce que ça a été bien dit il ya
eu un risque qui s'est imposée pendant
cette campagne atone que chloroformé par
la temporisation prises pour prix pour
composer le gouvernement c'est la parole
de jean luc mélenchon c'est la parole de
la nuque mais c'est un récit qui est
voilà la gauche vient de subir un
troisième 21 avril il ya un chemin qui
est forcé et macro à une cohabitation
cohabitation et de ce point de vue là ce
récit s'est imposé je nuancerais un
petit peu sur le fait que l'abstention
favorise automatiquement le compte des
mails macron sociologiquement c'est vrai
l'électorat gvt a pu souhaiter qu'un
électorat jeune mais quand on regarde la
composition des électeurs de l'animation
aussi des catégories sociales moyennes
supérieures voir pas seulement d'une
gauche radicale jeune et populaire issu
des quartiers qui pourraient aller voter
et c'est vrai que pourquoi les français
votent pourquoi les français ne votent
pas de plus en plus c'est pour une
logique que j'appelle de vanité du vote
voter c'est 20 voter c'est inutile les
jeux sont déjà faits et c'est là jean
luc mélenchon il ya de l'enjeu à imposer
une sorte de signification de sens du
vote sms qui est
réclameront les pouvoirs voir imposant
une quoi une commutation elle n'aura pas
lieu la phrase et lisez mon premier set
et une véritable idiotie additionnel
mais un coup de force à coups de fils
unique aseptiques qui a permis de créer
ce récit et c'est vrai que ce qu'on peut
anticiper pour dimanche mais dans une
version supporte bien sûr et alors quand
même forte mais ici il ya de l'enjeu
plus forte que oui c'est ça qui est
évident pour appeler ça la plus de 48%
c'était 50 heures et demie %
d'abstention unis pour cent de
participation s'était mis rien pour la
première fois sous la vème république un
scrutin national que l'abstention était
majoritaire ça n'était jamais arrivé
il y avait quand même eu une campagne
oui on va faire de vous le il y avait
une campagne en 2017 il y avait des
messages qui avait été envoyée notamment
avec la composition du gouvernement
l'aller le gouvernement des experts qui
répondait à un imaginaire mettons une
sportive aux sports un drh à l'emploi
etc il y avait un prémice de droite
edouard philippe qui avait mobilisé un
électorat de centre-droit qui avait
renforcé encore la majorité le
gouvernement sa composition n'a pas
envoyé le moindre message et c'est vrai
que je vois pas comment on va échapper
une abstention massive et c'est vrai que
la sq il la question qui se pose
j'essayais de donner quelques pistes
mais qui va profiter de cette absence
ont sur le papier c'est le camp ma
chronique mais attention à ce qui n'est
pas une élection en deux rounds si je
puis dire un premier tour favorable à la
nuque ps qui serait soit en tête soit en
possibilités du moins deux qualifiés
350-400 la serva sondages malgré un gros
taux qui rééquilibrait on va le regarder
dans le détail vous nous direz si au
fond la menace d'un chiffon rouge d'un
péril rouge qui
je t'aime du discours aujourd'hui peut
être peut être efficace pour l'année
pèse donc c'est un sondage heures
projection en sièges il faut toujours
prendre des précautions parce que c'est
très compliqué pour immoler son vers 19
heures deux voitures ne sont pas connues
voilà donc entre pour la nuque baisse
pour entre 195 et 230 députés pour
ensemble de 150 290 c'est un coup de
tonnerre cette enquête parce que 289
c'est la majorité absolue donc avec 290
on est dans la borne haute et donc on
n'est pas là loin d'être largement au
delà de la majorité absolue
40 55 députés pour les républicains 20
45 pour le rassemblement national ça
veut dire qu'à trois jours là on est à
trois jours du premier tour on peut dire
ce soir frédéric dabi que la majorité
présidentielle n'est pas sûr d'avoir une
majorité absolue elle n'est pas sûr
d'obtenir une majorité absolue ce
sondage vous avez raison de 2 2 me
d'exprimer toutes ces prudence une
projection ch ça se fait plus tôt à
l'issue d'un second tour nous avons des
faits second tour fictif pour voir les
phénomènes de reports de voix ce sondage
ne prend pas en compte les propos du
jeune mélenchon sur des violences
policières qui veut peut-être
remobiliser un électorat attaché à
l'ordre à la sécurité qui se
mobiliseraient pour faire barrage dès le
premier tour si je puis dire aujourd'hui
que mélenchon même si c'est plutôt au
second tour qui aura un réquilibrage
avec une tenue baisse qui a pas beaucoup
de réserves de voix et un sursaut
peut-être peut-être c'est fini potez de
participation et de vote anti du ps on
connaît l'adage de charles pasqua au
second tour on n'élimine mais c'est vrai
que ce sondage peut constituer une sorte
de coup de tonnerre dans la mesure où le
scénario qu'on a vu en 2002 et en 2007
en 2012 et surtout renouer 17 à savoir
que à l'issue d'une élection
présidentielle est logique de continuité
un effet de souffle qui fait que les
français confirment leur vote là on sent
un peu vous rappeliez bien 188 où
françois mitterrand et peut-être ou
anticipés ou accompagner le mouvement
avec sa phrase il n'est pas bon qu'un
seul parti le gouvernent fait peut-être
pas mettre leurs oeufs dans le panier et
quand emmanuel macron aujourd'hui
clairement agi de la menace du désordre
de la soumission de la banqueroute il
cite jaurès c'est pas rien quand même le
président qui ose cité jaurès le courage
c'est de chercher la vérité et de la
dire ce n'est pas de subir la loi du
mensonge et de faire écho aux huées
fanatiques c'est à jean luc mélenchon
qu'il s'adresse principalement avec ce
dernier discours très politique à mort
moi je pense beaucoup plus que la marine
le pen clairement parce que sous couvert
de dénoncer les deux extrêmes est de les
mettre sur le même plan et c'est en
réalité son discours est vraiment
orientés clairement contre jean luc
mélenchon je pense d'ailleurs que la
référence à jaurès n'est absolument pas
innocente parce que c'est une référence
pour la gauche et est notamment il a
fait beaucoup référence à la république
or on sait très bien que jean luc
mélenchon
qui était d'ailleurs vu par énormément
de gens il n'ya pas si longtemps comme
un grand républicain son image un peu
changé aujourd'hui mais on se souvient
que mélenchon avait dit a pas si
longtemps
quand il ya une perquisition la
république c'est moi c'est moi donc et
la macro lui dit non non non monsieur
mélenchon la république c'est pas vous
du tout la république c'est c'est moi
enfin cesser c'est moi qu'il incarne en
tout cas parce que c'est moi qui la
préside donc je pense qu'il y avait
clairement sa part ailleurs il y avait
aussi je pense un petit message
provenant d'europe quand même sur
l'ordre sur l'ordre des retraites aussi
d'ailleurs qu'il ait dit qu'il ferait
alors justement il y a les mots et puis
il ya les annonces c'est l'autre levier
pour faire campagne pour ces
législatives et se sont multipliées ces
annonces principalement sur le pouvoir
d'achat
tour d'horizon avec kathia gilder
à 72 heures du scrutin emmanuel macron
fait de la sécurité son thème de
campagne devant les gendarmes de gaillac
dans le tarn le chef de l'état annonce
le doublement de la présence des forces
de l'ordre sur la voie publique et il
confirme la création de 8500 poste de
magistrat et d'auxiliaires de justice
la veille c'est sa ministre de la santé
brigitte bourguignon qui a mis le paquet
sur l'hôpital elle a dévoilé ses
premières mesures face à la crise d
urgence les heures supplémentaires
payées double pour les médecins et le
personnel non médical la possibilité
pour les soignants retraité de prêter
main forte à l'hôpital enfin les élèves
infirmiers seront autorisés à travailler
avant même la remise de leur diplôme
ce mardi c'est elisabeth bornes qui a
sorti le carnet de chèques pour le
pouvoir d'achat sans même attendre
l'élection du nouveau parlement le 19
juin elle annonce le versement d'une
indemnité alimentaires dès la rentrée ce
sera une aide versée directement sur le
compte en banque
tenant une fois en une fois tenant
compte naturellement du nombre d'enfants
dans la famille et donc ça c'est quelque
chose qui peut se mettre en place à la
rentrée matignon annonce aussi hausse de
4% pour les pensions de retraite
indexées sur l'inflation dès le mois
d'août enfin la remise de 18 centimes
par litre est maintenue pour tous les
automobilistes jusqu'à la fin du mois
d'août
jean-philippe de rezé ça serve un grand
classique systématiquement un président
élu à ce temps pour les législatives de
campagne pour commencer à amorcer un
programme d' annonces qui seront
réalisés s'il a la majorité à
l'assemblée nationale et là c'est vrai
ce que disait carole n'y a pas forcément
de projet il ya quelques annonces qui a
des urgences y a pas de vision c'est
nouveau ça vous diriez parce que
justement on est dans une période
particulière avec un président réélu oui
sans cohabitation un président réélu
sans cohabitation et ce en campagne
parce qu on est au terme d'un
quinquennat qui est quand même pour le
moins tout à fait exceptionnelle
entre la crise sanitaire qui se termine
qui a duré en gros de 2020-2022 plus la
crise diplomatique internationale avec
l'ukraine on a eu une campagne qui a été
complètement torpiller et qui a permis à
aimer mais le maquereau de surfer sur la
vague si j'ose dire de faire appel
campagne de se mobiliser sur les sujets
internationaux
et de deux il avait été élu par accident
en 2017 parce que il y avait une
convergence de deux facteurs le rôle la
non candidature de françois hollande et
la sphère fillon qui ont permis d'être
élu et il a été élu par défaut en 2022
parce qu'il est personne d'autre en
mesure de le concurrencer et il a été
naturellement reporter et c'est pour ça
que faute de campagne faute de
discussion de projets très peu et donc
très peu de mesures ensuite à
concrétiser il est dans son rôle dans
les annonces mais effectivement il
serait beaucoup plus sensé que ce soit
le premier ministre qui commence à
diffuser ce soir on a vu il y avait deux
bornes qui est un petit peu évoque
certaines choses mais elle a une voix
qui portent moins que celle du chef de
l'état il ya une question de légitimité
il ya une question de deux rôles aussi
on sait dans un cas implique que cette
prison un public qui dirige mais en 2017
c'avait été dit par frédéric dabi tout à
l'heure il y avait eu ce jeu cette
séduction d'électorat en nommant edouard
philippe meyer venait de la gauche
edouard philippe qui venait de la droite
et ses doigts philippe qui est aussi à
la ronde bâle la dynamique d'après
élection ça c'est vrai séduire les
électeurs dhabi en même temps les
électeurs voient la questionner
interrogé observés sont sensibles à ses
annonceurs on est dans un véritable
urgence sur le pouvoir d'achat avec une
inflation à 5 % est-ce que ça c'est
efficace est ce qu'au fond voilà ça peut
se traduire directement dans les urnes
oui en tout cas c'est vrai qu'il ya de
risques de donner de paraître
fait annoncer des mesures électoralistes
mais ce risque est infiniment moins fort
que de risques de l'inaction et c'est
vrai que jamais un enjeu comme le
pouvoir d'achat a été aussi fort dans le
discours des français il structure tout
il écrase tout ça devient une sorte
d'obsession pour les français on a
diffusé une enquête avant-hier où nous
avons 50% des français qui déclarent
avoir ressenti une dégradation de leur
pouvoir d'achat depuis ces derniers mois
ses 14 points de plus que la même
enquête administrés en octobre 2021 où
déjà on parlait du pouvoir d'achat
marine le pen s'était emparé de ce thème
dès la rentrée s'est arrondi nom de
l'inquiétude des français seul pouvoir
d'achat sur la question de centres de la
santé qui est la première préoccupation
des français sur la question de l'école
et c'est vrai que le risque de paraître
électoraliste et infiniment moindres que
nous le fait que de ne pas annoncer des
choses surtout que l'offre
programmatique de la nuque baisse on
peut juger sa démagogie qui réalisable
et pas finançable il ya le blocage des
prix et à une forte augmentation du smic
ça sera sans doute cette question du
poids lâche un des premiers déterminant
du vote
surtout il ya une forme de récits chez
la nuit baisse rappelez vous pendant la
campagne emmanuel macron et présenté son
programme on nous avait vendu un grand
récit une grande projection et puis
finalement ils nous avaient fait
emmanuel macron une sorte de powerpoint
avec une multiplication de deux mesures
et là c'est pareil je trouve qu'une
sorte de stratégie à mon sens un peu
mortifère de barrage au second tour
d'exemple présidentielle c'était barrage
contre le rn qui était au second tour là
une nouvelle fois vous avez raison
carole on n'a pas de projet réellement
avancé par la majorité on a encore une
fois une barre à ronchamp d'adversaires
mais un barrage face à jean luc
mélenchon et je ne suis pas sûr en tout
cas que les stratèges macro 10 juillet
ça au départ mais il nous manque un gros
récit a effectivement un grand projet
ce que j'adore y a pas de représentant
de la macro ni sur ce plateau mais il a
parlé quand même d'investissements
d'avenir dans l'écologie les services
publics l'école l'hôpital ça ils
essayent d'avoir une vision à 10 20 ans
hier au parlement européen ses doigts
sur thermiques ont été interdits aux
défraiements opération vraiment ramé
division ça oui mais tout ça est balayée
très rapidement on avait déjà dit ça à
l'occasion de la campagne présidentielle
c'est qu'on peut pas dire qu'il ya pas
eu de débat parce qu'il ya eu il ya eu
une campagne avec la percée des mourres
à l'automne des choses comme ça bon et
puis l'ukraine savoir la place de la
france dans le monde tu as n'étaient pas
des débats nul mais on n'a jamais pu
rentrer dans le détail des sujets et
pardon moi je suis très sensible au
sujet sur l'école j'ai écrit un livre
sur scène mais à chaque fois mais c'est
superficiel voilà on donc je trouve pas
qu'on rentre dans les sujets sains et
l'envoûtant sont vives et ses plastiques
où il ya vraiment
ce que dit qui est extrêmement justes il
ya cette élection présidentielle n'a pas
joué sa fonction cathartique
traditionnel où on a débattu les sujets
ont été faites tranché et jeu mais je
mets dans le débat une donnée ifop
absolument inédite nous avons posé après
l'élection présidentielle laquelle sont
d'optimisme pour l'avenir
traditionnellement il progresse toujours
après l'élection présidentielle pour la
première fois l'optimisme pour l'avenir
pour soi et ses enfants le p6 de
projection qui se joue sur l'école votre
sujet de prédilection a fortement baissé
ça n'était jamais arrivé n'ont pas
d'état de grâce si je vous entends pas
de projets
cités justin nos éminents confrères
alain duhamel absolument qui dit
jean luc mélenchon va se faire élire sur
son programme emmanuel macron sur sa
personne encore sa personne un mot aux
législatives
est en opposition aux tic il a toujours
été comme ça il a toujours été en
opposition aux autres pendant cinq ans
il s'est placé en opposition à marine le
pen pourquoi parce que il a ainsi porté
marine le pen au second tour une
deuxième fois il savait que c'était sa
seule façon de s'en sortir seul quand
même oui non et bien sûr mais quand vous
faites de quelqu'un à votre premier
principal adversaire automatiquement
vous devez donner une légitimité vous
faites grimper voulu donner de la
visibilité est évidemment là la
compagnie elle a aidé lui a donné du
répondant et il savait c'était sans
doute une vision stratégique que avec
marine le pen au second tour il allait
l'emporter à nouveau maintenant il a une
autre préoccupation au delà d'obtenir là
une majorité si possible absolue à
l'assemblée nationale c'est d'empêcher
que marine le pen où le front national
extrême droite l'emportent dans cinq ans
parce que sinon ce sera ça son héritage
on sera moi je pourrais pas être
candidat celui qui vient après moi c'est
moi qui ai amené l'extrême droite on est
donc sa préoccupation elle est là donc
je pense qu'il change d'adversaires et
il table désormais sur mélenchon et
départ effectivement les pronostics qui
sont que mélenchon baisse est beaucoup
plus forte que l'extrême droite l'a en
tout cas dans le terme de terme de
sièges et que donc il vaut mieux taper
sur sur sur la gauche à cela s'ajoute
aussi le fait que la nuque est une
coalition là où le front national leur
assemblée nationale reste toujours seul
la gauche a réussi à se coaliser sur un
point d'équilibré radical qui est con on
en revient à notre thématique du début
comme la gauche al ce point dès qu'ils
pratiquent à lille va lui être difficile
quand même de remporter des duels face à
des macros nist plutôt centriste en tout
cas alors tu as des candidats de la
collation ça c'est très important parce
que dimanche c'est davantage de voix
contre et réservé qualité d'alliance et
en soutien tout à fait juste ça il faut
avoir il faut bien dire aux
téléspectateurs que l'abstention aura un
effet sur les configurations de ce2 ont
refait un peu de pédagogie si vous
voulez voir être qualifié pour le second
tour il faut être premier ou arrivé à
douze ennemis % des inscrits ce qui veut
dire que ce qui avait été
une configuration très répandues par
exemple en 1997 la dernière élection
législative autonome si je puis dire
delà de la présidentielle il y avait 80
ou 90 triangulaire si je me trompe pas
là il y en aura quasiment aucune en 2017
avec une abstention sans doute moins
forte il y avait une circonscription
dans la 2e circonscription une
triangulaire ception de l'aube skis ce
qui vient d'être dit et que je
compléterai c'est que du fait au
positionnement central les candidats de
la majorité présidentielle qu ils seront
face à la nuque ps pourront bénéficier
être le réceptacle de voix des droits
tout voir de droite extrême au nom à
tous sauf mélenchon et quand ils seront
face à à droite ou à des candidatures de
droite extrême ils auront un renfort
peut-être modeste mais en forme compris
les lois de mélenchon alors peut-être
que c'est à cette droite modérée qui
pourraient voter pour le camp de la
majorité au deuxième tour qu'il a dit
ceci pour être sûr que son programme est
véritablement sérieux je vous le dis
c'est avec beaucoup de clarté il n'y a
pas d'argent magique et donc que les
projets qui seront présentés dans
quelques jours et dès le 12 soit clair
qui n'explique pas comment il le
financent le financent par des impôts
cacher ou par une dette qui nous fera
vibrer encore davantage et qu'il ne
finance pas tout en supprimant de
l'activité économique
est un programme d'impôts massifs à
venir voilà le sérieux budgétaire il n'y
a pas d'argent magique l one care au
fond ils essayent de jeu faire de jouer
le vote utile dès le premier tour c'est
à qui ils essayent de faire essayer de
ramener un maximum la droite modérée la
gauche modérée au pour être le plus fort
possible et créer une dynamique de
deuxième en l'occurrence plutôt la
droite modérée effectivement et aussi
les retraités grappillé majorité me
disais il ya une semaine les vieux nous
aime on aime les vieux ça se passe
plutôt pas trop mal quand ça se passe
comme ça effectivement c'est aussi pour
ça qu'il m'a qu'on dit ça et
rappelez vous quand edouard philippe
faisait quelques sorties notamment sur
le budget une sorte d' austérité en tout
cas de garder les comptes publics à flot
on nous disait en fait c'est pas si mal
parce que le père tape dur seedorf l'ipc
nous ça nous sert plutôt dans notre
segment notre électorat de droite là
emmanuel macron est en train de
reprendre un petit peu cette logique là
et c'est aussi important de mots lisez
pour lui tout ce ce centre-droit voir
cette droite trail est réglable et il
refait dure même complètement non parce
qu'il a un mot pour la droite il a un
bon pour la gauche il renforce les
retraites et en même temps il dit qu'il
n'a pas d'argent match lui qui me l'a
fait ça pendant cinq ans
je vais pas vous demander de pronostics
mais ce qui semble étrange quand même à
ce stade de la campagne c'est qu'on a
l'impression que les français ne veulent
pas lui donner une large majorité
confortable veut pas non plus donné la
majorité à jean luc mélenchon encore
moins à marine le pen donc à une forme
d'un satisfaction face à l'offre
aujourd'hui une sorte peut-être
d'indifférence ou deux
re de retrait après une période si
difficile pour les français un
quinquennat de crise une campagne
présidentielle je le disais qu'il n'a
pas réglé grand chose en tout cas il y
aura plutôt un vote pour les moins pire
mais malgré tout je pense que l'effet de
souffle présidentiel le fait que les
justes et si je dois quand même très
fortement indexés sur scrum présence
elle va jouer à minima peut-être façon
1988 s'il ya une majorité relative mais
en tout cas va jouer au profit avant
tout de la majorité présidentielle merci
on va s'arrêter là rendez vous dimanche
soir 19h30 plus pour 4h même plus plus
de quatre heures de direct avec toute la
chaîne parlementaire nos équipes sont
évidemment sur le pont ce les moins
qu'on puisse dire merci à vous merci et
à très vite sur lcp on va s'arrêter à
présent sur une tragédie catastrophe les
mots manquent pour décrire le martyre
que vivent les ukrainiens et
particulièrement les enfants deux
enfants meurent chaque jour en ukraine
nous apprend l'unicef certains sont
abattus de sang-froid visé alors qu'il
tente de fuir en voiture avec leur
famille la grande reporter doan bui a
recueilli les témoignages de plusieurs
familles c'est là une de l'ops
aujourd'hui bouleversant de photos à
l'appui on a plein de questions à lui
poser comme les skis ce sujet de marco
pommier regarder
si on vous envie doan bui c'est parce
que vous revenez tout juste d'ukraine
avec un constat terrible chaque jour
depuis le début de la guerre deux
enfants sont tués une tragédie jamais vu
en europe depuis la seconde guerre
mondiale d'après l'unicef dans ce
conflit des enfants sur les premières
victimes certains sont même tuer
beaucoup sont blessés doan bui vous avez
épousé le métier de journaliste grand
reporter à l'ops vous êtes aussi
écrivaine de vous nous retenons vos
multiples distinctions dont le prix
albert londres en 2013 pour votre
reportage les fantômes du fleuve une
rencontre avec des immigrés qui tentent
de franchir les portes de l'europe entre
la grèce et la turquie le prix albert
londres comme pour tous les journalistes
c'est évidemment un rêve c'est un graal
ont souvent l'immigration c'est un sujet
politique mais très abstrait et là moi
ce que j'ai voulu faire dans mon travail
c'est redonner un visage et redonnait
une histoire à ceux qui n'en ont pas
votre actualité c'est donc ce grand
reportage sur l'enfance assassiné en
ukraine avec cette photo bouleversante à
la une de loeb cette semaine abuja vous
avez constaté l'étendue des atrocités
commises par les russes des crimes de
guerre plus de 400 civils tués dont 32
enfants des innocents au destin tragique
comme igor 15 ans abattu de sang froid
en sortant d'une cave ou nastia
mitraillé dans une voiture agonisant
dans un jardin d'enfants
nous pensons que ce sont des crimes de
guerre et que tout cela sera reconnu par
le monde comme un génocide nous savons
qu'il y a des milliers de personnes
tuées torturées avec des membres coupés
des filles violées et des enfants
assassines des crimes de guerre des
récits terrifiants voilà bientôt cent
jours que vladimir poutine martyrise
l'ukraine avec ce bilan terrible pour
les enfants
262 tué 4 115 blessés 139 disparu et 2,2
millions de déplacés
alors douanne be cette question les
familles meurtries de bouche à
pourront-elles un jour s'en remettre à
vous la parole
bonsoir d'un médecin et merci beaucoup
d'avoir accepté notre invitation merci
pour ce reportage bouleversant
remarquable dans locks avec avec la
photographie en une mais aussi beaucoup
d'autres photos dans le dossier de gan
jurack ces familles pontet s'en remettre
je pense qu'on peut jamais se remettre
de la mort d'un enfant d'ailleurs il ya
même pas de mots pour dire une mère qui
a perdu un enfant donc le mot n'existe
pas parce que c'est ce qui est plus
horrible donc en fait non je pense pas
qu'on puisse se remettre du deuil d'un
enfant vous vous avez en tout cas mis
des mots parce que c'était très
compliqué d'arriver à faire parler les
familles les survivants oui tout à fait
comment vous avez réussi parce que vous
dites qu'ils sont encore sidéré oui ils
suffoquent mais qui a aussi besoin de
raconter owen jones et robert en termes
qui re quand il revenait d quand il
avait expliqué qu'il y avait et tous les
survivants avaient été pris d'une espèce
de délire il y avait cette volonté de
témoigner très forte mais dès qu'ils
commencent à raconter il ne parvenait
pas à trouver les mots il suffoquait en
fait j'ai vraiment pensé à ce début de
l'espèce humaine donc le livre de robert
antelme quand on arrivait à bout de
chats parce qu'en fait à chaque fois les
récits qu'on a recueilli les mots se
bousculent et parfois c'était très
confus les gens pleuraient comme si
c'était enfin il disait pas comme s'il
était en état de choc ils sont en état
de choc donc forcément leur si le récit
il arrive de façon très confuse et y
avait toujours un moment d'ailleurs où
parfois on me tendait un appareil en
téléphone avec des photos de cadavres ou
des vidéos de cadavres comme si eux
mêmes de pouvoir il est pas comprendre
ce qui s'était passé parce qu'en fait
ils ont fait des règles qui sont sidérés
puis s'attendait pas cette sauvagerie en
fait ils s'attendaient ils s'attendaient
d'ailleurs pas au début de la guerre
la plupart et aubier bout de chasse est
vraiment une ville cossue c'était là que
tous les gens de kiev s'installer
très cossu lui il y avait plein de senna
sanatorium des forêts c'est l'endroit où
les gens allaient quand il avait un
petit peu d'argent et qui voulait être
un petit pot câble et il ya plein de
gens même de kiev au début de la guerre
qui se dit on va aller se réfugier à
bout de chars si la guerre éclate pour
vous dire le décalage donc ce
déferlement de violence et surtout à
butch a par rapport à ce qui s'est passé
et l'horreur qui s'est passé à quoi
khayr pinet borodianka c'est que et bois
ya eu des bombardements mais - et en
fait là il ya vraiment eu plein de gens
qui ont été abattus à porter fac vous
expliquer très bien à travers ce long
reportage c'est que c'est pas à l'aip
concernant les enfants c'est pas gaza
c'est pas deux des enfants ou des civils
bombardés à l'aveuglé là pour les
enfants de boudhha pour ces personnes en
civil sont des adultes ils sont abattues
à bout portant certains sont fui dans
leurs familles on leur tire dessus ils
sont visés ils sont visés donc c'est
vrai qu'il ya eu trois mille cinq cents
personnes qui n'ont pas été évacués qui
sont restés abuja et ils ont trouvé pour
l'instant 416 corps dont 32 enfants
quand on repense à ces chiffes alors
j'aime pas les chiffres parce que
souvent les chiffres enfin c'est pas que
j'aime pas les chiffres mais les
chiffres souvent c'est des statistiques
on n'a pas les histoires derrière mais
c'est énorme ça veut dire qu'en fait une
personne sur dix a été a été tué et
plusieurs personnes m'ont dit ça en fait
c'était il avait l'impression ils m'ont
dit on était cachée dans nos caves et on
avait l'impression qu'on était comme
dans un camp de concentration par feu
parce que les gens qui sont sortis
parfois ils se sont fait tirer comme des
la parler parce que ça c'est très fort
dans le reportage c'est la cave de
vordel les captifs de la cave il ya un
grand père qui s'appelle leonid qui perd
son son petit fils qui s'appelle igor
lui les a battus à l'entrée de la cave
qu'est ce qui s'est passé dans ses caves
et comment les rues sont humiliés
torturés
et tués alors en fait ça c'est juste à
côté de bout de champ c'est dans le
district de boudhha et
ce qui s'est passé c'est qu'il ya une
centaine de personnes qui se sont
réfugiées dans la cave petit à petit se
sont agglutinés l'alors évidemment là
aussi les récits sont son sont confus
parce que tout le monde était dans le
noir et les gens ne se connaissaient pas
forcément dans la cave ce qu'on sait
c'est que voilà il ya eu par exemple ya
eu des groupes qui ont été séparées
hommes et femmes et les hommes étaient
étaient battus jusqu'à ce déféqué sur
eux mêmes ils n'avaient pas le droit de
se changer et armés liés au si on les
habille et déshabille et pour voir si
art pour voir s'il y avait des tatouages
ou pas mais en fait on m'a raconté aussi
effectivement une scène où certains ont
été obligés de se déshabiller dans le
froid et de se mettre à courir en se
tenant en quant à la queue leu leu en
chenille et ce qui s'est passé pour igor
igor donc qui venait juste d'avoir 15
ans un moment ils ont jeté trois
grenades lacrymogènes dans la cave donc
la cave j'y suis allé c'est vraiment un
endroit il ya peu pas du tout respire et
si on vous jette c'est un endroit
totalement totalement fermé où s'étaient
réfugiés des gens avaient une toilette
et puis sinon il devait demander aux
russes de pouvoir aller dehors dont
qu'ils ont jetés c'est que ces trois
grenades à l'intérieur de la caf dont
tout le monde s'est mis un petit peu à
courir en panique n'arrivais plus à
respirer
et en fait igor est sorti de la porte là
où il y avait l'escouade l'escouade
russe et il a été abattu d'une balle
dans la nuque et donc c'est un gamin qui
est avec 15 ans moi ce qui m'a
bouleversée c'est qu'en fait leonid son
grand père a tenu un journal de tout
temps fait attiré le début de la guerre
même d'avant emphatique et un journal où
on fait avant c'était voilà les pommes
de terre poussant jardin les cigognes
sont arrivés enfin et à chaque fois il
marque là la température et et le jour
de la mort de deux de son de son fils de
son petit fils il a marqué 3 mars
aujourd'hui ces salopards ont tué igor
juste ça lafley créé après est en fait
ce qui est terrible c'est que ils n'ont
même pas pu récupérer le corps le corps
tout de suite parce qu'un fou c'est que
même ça vraiment une histoire qui m'a
été racontée la dépouille a été
abandonnée ce jeune igor devant un bus
sont donc pas en buisson et donc
tout de suite c'est sa mère et sa grand
mère qui est enfermé dans la cave ont
entendu ce qui s'était passé
mais c'est impossible de récupérer les
corps parce que les sols danone le
refuser et en fait ils n'ont pu
récupérer que au départ enfin un moment
les soldats sont partis dieu sait
pourquoi son son parti de cette cave et
sont partis ailleurs et c'est là alors
un moment il y en avait plus qu'un ou
deux c'est là qu'ils ont récupéré corps
et qui l'ont mis sous perron il avait
été jeté dans un buisson et après ils
ont ils enterraient dans le jardin vous
raconter d'ailleurs très bien comment on
font accéder aux corps récupérer les
corps leur donner une sépulture c'est
aussi l'obsession de ces familles
aujourd'hui oui tout à fait et ben ça
m'a fait penser au mythe d'antigone
parce que c'est ça je l'entende eu
tellement de fois ces corps qui ont été
abandonnées c'était impossible de les
récupérer parce que c'était trop
dangereux donc c'est pour ça qu'à bout
de chaque ans la ville a été libérée
qu'on a eues ces images terribles et ce
n'était pas que 20 corps en fait c'était
beaucoup plus c'était des corps partout
dans la vie qui n'avaient pas pu être
récupérés parce que c'était trop
dangereux de les récupérer certains
avaient été enterrés à la va vite dans
les cours dans les jardins il ya eu une
fosse commune qui a été fait là aussi à
la va-vite ray de près d'église où il y
avait quand même sens et scor dont des
corps d'enfants est en fait ce désespoir
la 2d maire de de perdre son enfant mais
de ne pas pouvoir récupérer la dépouille
de la personne que vous aimez de la
laisser comme ça à l'air libre alors en
sachant tout le monde m'a dit
heureusement qu'il faisait froid en ce
mois de mars heureusement qu'il faisait
froid il faisait from il y avait des
animaux il y avait les il y avait les
chiens qui tournait autour donc laisser
ces corps à bas pendant pendant
l'occupation durer un mois aujourd'hui
il ya quand même un travail qui est fait
d'identification
parmi les témoignages très fort aussi il
ya celui de l'ida qui est à l'hôpital
deux bouts de chat qui est chargé
d'accueillir la presse qui a filmé qui a
documenté toutes les opérations
chirurgicales
les bras
on ampute les petits martyrs qui se
succèdent à l'hôpital comme un cri jeté
au visage du monde
ça il ya aussi ça c'est à dire ya aussi
des gens qui veulent crier ne nous
oubliez pas raconter ça ça revient tout
le temps c'est à dire que oui je pense
que les ukrainiens ont l'impression que
peut-être que nous fatiguons de ces
images d'horreur que nous nous fatiguons
de cette guerre donc il ya ce besoin
vraiment de de témoigner et oui à
l'hôpital il filme tout est donc
conseillé voulais raconter l'histoire
des patients vous le raconter l'histoire
de cette petite fille qui a vu sa mère
mourir devant ses yeux et qui lui écrit
tous les jours une lettre à sa maman
d'anciens livres voulait il voulait
raconter tout ça effectivement la
justice va passer la justice
internationale
pose la question contre un état
nucléaire la russie de poutine la
justice je crée même commence à plus que
quand on travaille à les procureurs
travaillent tous là dessus il ya déjà
dédé voilà d'aidé des soldats qui ont
été qui ont été identifiés on a
l'impression en fait que toute cette
audace est devenue une immense scène de
crémant parce qu'on continue à trouver
des corps aujourd'hui dans les forêts
parfois on trouve un vin qui dépassent
un pied qui dépasse donc en fait les non
seulement continuer à trouver des corps
ont continué à essayer d'en identifier
et les familles continuent à rechercher
leurs disparus et les orphelins beaucoup
de réfugiés parmi les enfants il ya plus
de 2 millions de de réfugiés chrétiens
dans toute l'europe que vont-ils devenir
les orphelins ça c'est la grande
question parce que vous avez un pays
exsangue donc les déjà les orphelinats
donc les enfants placés ils ont été
déplacées de l'est vers l'ouest
comment le pays va faire pour pour s'en
occuper alors que voilà l'économie
à terre avec la guerre et ceux qui ont
été déplacés dans les pays voisins comme
la pologne aussi commander ce qu'au bout
d'un moment voilà c'est ça fait le ya
beaucoup de réfugiés qui sont
accueillies plus les enfants
effectivement la question reste
totalement ouverte en tout cas merci
beaucoup merci donne bruit pour ce
travail ça s'appelle l'enfance assassiné
c'est plusieurs pages et c'est là une de
l'ops qui qui sort en kiosque
aujourd'hui c'est leur art présent
d'accueillir nos a franchi pour leur
parti pris ce soir c'est la dernière
chronique d'elsa mondain gavât et de son
carnet de campagne avant la soirée
électorale sur lcp dimanche soir brandon
ouaret va nous parler de de ces archives
qui nous montre des premiers ministres à
la pêche aux voix on en a parlé un peu
pendant notre débat et puis un coup de
coeur ce soit celui de delphine
sabattier pour un livre un livre sur les
mathématiques signé david des six on va
découvrir tout cela bonsoir les
affranchis bonsoir et merci d'être là
alors on commence comme chaque soir avec
vous alsace et la dernière dernière
chronique vous nous a fait vivre cette
campagne avec ses infos coulisses de
façon à la fois précise et trépidante
alors à trois jours du scrutin vous
vouliez revenir un peu de pédagogie
quand même on va tous aller voter
dimanche sur les anges de ce vote
exactement de ce vote de ces votes
puisqu'il s'agit est bien de
577 scrutins locaux
577 et le nombre de députés à élire ici
à l'assemblée nationale et le scénario
rêvé évidemment pour chaque formation
politique est bien c'est d'avoir une
majorité absolue c'est à dire au moins
289 députés alors soit tout seul soit
avec une union où une confédération de
partir c'est le cas pour la majorité
présidentielle ensemble avec la
république en marche le modem et
horizons ou encore la nuque la france
insoumise le parti socialiste les
communistes les verts alors à défaut
d'une majorité absolue bas on peut se
contenter d'une majorité relative mais
ça ça veut dire qu'il faut essayer de
bâtir des alliances des coalitions avec
d'autres groupes parlementaires puis si
on perd les élections dont on se
retrouve dans l'opposition et ici à
l'assemblée nationale au palais bourbon
on ne parle pas de parti politique mais
de groupes parlementaires oui c'est
vraiment les groupes qui comptent les
députés et lui s'organisent en groupes
qui dit groupe 10 temps de parole dit
moyens alloués aussi pour avoir
notamment des collaborateurs alors il
faut au moins quinze députés pour faire
un groupe sinon on siège avec les
non-inscrits et c'est beaucoup plus
difficile d'exister politiquement à
l'assemblée nationale on l'a bien vu
pendant cette législature avec le
rassemblement national alors justement
le rn tête-à-queue complet côté
stratégie ils ont commencé plutôt
modeste et il assiste et de l'ambition
en fin de campagne pas exactement on
voit le rassemblement national a fait
une campagne un peu étrange il a eu
énormément de mal à capitaliser sur sa
place de finaliste si bien qu'on jean
luc mélenchon leur a dérobé les habits
de première opposante à emmanuel macron
le rn qui semble se réveiller à quelques
jours du scrutin écoutez on a fait un
petit montage voilà ce que disait jordan
bardella c'est le président par intérim
du rm il ya un mois et ce matin
l'enjeu de cette élection présidentielle
est de savoir quel va être l'opposition
à emmanuel mâcon pendant cinq ans est de
permettre aux français de décider qui
vont être leurs avocats face à la
brutalité et la violence de la politique
de monsieur macron je pense que nous
pouvons arriver en tête et je dis à nos
électeurs ne laissez pas les pleins
pouvoirs à emmanuel macron aidez nous à
vous aider aidez nous à vous défendre
pendant cinq ans donc si nos électeurs
se déplacent dimanche nous arriveront en
tête voilà on est passé de on sera dans
l'opposition à on peut gagner le arena
compris peut-être un peu tard que pour
mobiliser ses électeurs s'ils se
déplacerait ses électeurs uniquement
s'il pense avoir une chance de gagner
côté sondages à trois jours du premier
tour on le répète les sondages sont à
prendre avec des pincettes surtout
lorsqu'il s'agit de projections en
sièges le rn entre 20 et 50 sièges c'est
toujours plus que reconquête le parti
d'eric zemmour qui pourrait en finir
avec une poignée petite poignée députés
seulement exactement entre 1 et 4 selon
les sondages mais pour parti d'eric
zemmour et bien ce sera la faute des
autres écoutez à guillaume pelletier il
est vice-président exécutif de
reconquête on aurait aimé bien entendu
on le répète souvent cette union des
droites et des patriotes que les
dirigeants des républicains les
dirigeants du rassemblement national
accepte notre main tendue et si tel
avait été le cas nous serions en mesure
d'avoir probablement 150 ou 200 députés
à l'assemblée nationale je dis et je
répète que les dirigeants aient l'air et
rn porte
encore ce matin une immense et très
lourde responsabilité à l'ennemi rien de
plus que 72 heures de suspense avant le
premier tour de ces élections
législatives il faut le dire très très
incertaine et on fera tout cela vous
vous ferez quoi je serai dans le 20e
arrondissement de paris pour suivre ces
biens d'église la guerre des gauches
19h30 sur lcp on compte sur vous brandon
les ministres les premiers ministres en
campagne ça c'est se battre à nouveau on
a vu les abeilles bornes en campagne
dans le calvados il faut remonter à caen
pour le premier premier ministre en
campagne aux législatives
la première fois qu'un premier ministre
était candidat aux législatives c'était
en 1967 avec georges pompidou c'était
d'ailleurs sa première candidature une
élection c'est une élection singulière
puisque c'est la seule et unique fois
dans l'histoire de la vème république
que tous les ministres d'un même
gouvernement sont candidats c'est une
stratégie à laquelle pompidou a ses
raisons
la plupart des ministres sont
originaires du parlement il est donc
normal qu'ils fassent la preuve qu'ils
n'ont pas simplement d'un confiance du
président de la république mais qu'ils
ôtent aussi celle de leurs électeurs
tout cela ne déplace pas l' équilibre
des pouvoirs mais je crois dans une
certaine mesure au contraire la sueur
mais pompidou s'impose largement dès le
premier tour avec ce chiffre 62% des
suffrages exprimés mais ça n'empêche pas
la droite annoncé très largement
vainqueur de frôler une défaite
historique elle ne dispose que d'une
très courte majorité à l'assemblée 4 247
sièges sur les 480 7
alors c'est à moi de vous relancer donc
bon et bien je le fais à présent en 1978
on en parlait dans du premier débat
s'est marié giscard d'estaing qui alors
premier ministre engage directement
alors c'est raymond barre du coup le
premier ministre qui va mener une
campagne
de premier ministre une campagne très
active contenue justement du risque très
élevé d'une victoire de la gauche et les
vives tensions entre l'udf le
nouvellement créée par valéry giscard
d'estaing l'union pour la démocratie
française et le rpr chiraquien oblige
forcément le premier ministre raymond
barre à monter au créneau je suis arrivé
les embruns lyon qu'il était souhaitable
que puisque j'étais premier ministre
en dépit de mes occupations et de mes
obligations
il fallait comme on dit aller au charbon
par conséquent j'irai au charbon et vous
saurez bientôt
alors on annoncé un raz-de-marée de la
gauche c'est finalement la droite
divisée qui l'emportent et regardez ce
chiffre dans la 4e circonscription du
rhône raymond barre et élu dès le
premier tour avec près de 56% des
suffrages exprimés il est maintenu à son
poste de premier ministre et c'est
d'ailleurs la dernière législative avoir
renouvelé la majorité sortante
1997 le premier ministre se présente à
des législatives inattendu là le
président jacques chirac décide à la
surprise générale de dissoudre
l'assemblée où la droite est pourtant
largement majoritaire
la raison c'est qu'il devait s'attaquer
prochainement notamment autour de la
rentrée à des réformes qui seraient
jugées impopulaires alors il a préféré
justement d'anticiper ces élections est
le premier ministre alain juppé se lance
dans la bataille confiant au point de
donner une leçon à ses électeurs et je
demande notamment à tous ceux qui nous
disent qu'ils vont se défouler au
premier tour avant de se reporter sur
nous au deuxième tour c'est bien beau de
se défouler au premier tour mais quand
on se défoule trop après on se fout le
complètement et quand on soulage fit
terminer la compétition deux semaines
plus tard au soir du second tour la
cheville et très douloureuse la
dissolution décidée par le président de
la république a donné la parole au
peuple français je souhaite bonne chance
à ceux qui vont maintenant gouverner la
france
et je souhaite bonne chance à la france
new deux défaites et alain juppé
démissionne la gauche retrouve matignon
avec lionel jospin lot de consolation
quand même pour alain juppé puisqu'il
remporte sa circonscription en gironde
avec 54 % au second tour alors si ça
devait arriver le 19 juin prochain pour
la majorité pas sûr que les lots de
consolation ils suffisent à emmanuel
macron point c'est sur ces risques et
pas pour elisabeth bornes dans le
calvados après ils n'avaient facile
apparemment ça sert cours pourraient oui
tous les sondages la donnent en tout cas
afin d'y ce qu'elle peut a largement
gagné mais c'est vrai que cette élection
est incertaine et surtout la
mobilisation qui va se mobiliser qui va
aller voter ce sera vraiment la réponse
dimanche delphine sabattier coup de
coeur pour un livre ce soir vous allez
nous parler mathématiques
mathematica paru chez chez seuil alors
si je vous dis que c'est un ouvrage qui
a été écrit par un mathématicien qui a
été chercheur pendant dix ans au cnrs en
mathématiques pures j'ai peur qu'avec
quelques uns qui partent en courant
alors s'il vous plaît restez parce que
justement ce n'est pas du tout un livre
de mathématiques c'est vraiment la
révélation d'un secret david b6 donc
l'auteur de cet ouvrage nous et nous
explique enfin pourquoi il y a ceux qui
aiment et puis ceux qui détestent
tellement les mathématiques et cela n'a
rien à voir évidemment avec les théories
farfelues de la bosse des maths ou alors
une cruelle fatalité on ne naît pas bon
ou nuls en maths alors pourquoi on a ce
sentiment qu'on n'est pas tous égaux
enfin rapport aux maths c'est vrai parce
que en fait en général la plupart du
temps ceux qui sont doués en bâtissons
autodidacte parce qu'on nous a pas non
plus révélé qu'elle était la bonne façon
d'aborder cette matière et puis à des
obstacles quand même le langage un qui
est
indéchiffrable même hermétique mais
conduit inventé les mathématiciens
justement pour expliquer leurs idées et
puis il y à l'obstacle de cette
impossibilité d'apprendre par imitation
ce serait tellement plus simple mais là
les objets mathématiques sont invisibles
et puis enfin il ya ce que l'auteur
décrit dans son ouvrage comme un
véritable désastre c'est l'enseignement
des mathématiques à l'école un échec
donc est en partie liée à cette
complexité d'expliquer ce que l'on voit
dans sa tête mais pourtant il va bien
falloir trouver une solution parce que
les mathématiques aujourd'hui c'est
aussi puissant est essentiel que la
lecture ou l'écriture j'imagine que dans
ce contexte le retour des maths même en
option au lycée vous fait plaisir alors
c'est quand même un retour notable c'est
vrai que c'est quand même une des
premières annonce qui a été faite par le
président emmanuel macron à peine réélu
donc il a visiblement entendu la grogne
pour beaucoup cette réforme blanc caire
ou lycées a eu pour effet de détourner
les jeunes et les jeunes filles encore
plus d'une discipline fondamentale pour
comprendre pour bâtir aussi l'avenir
donc la colère elle avait saisi chez pas
si vous en rappeler mais jusqu'aux
grands patrons 1,30 poids lourds de
l'économie française ont signé un
manifeste dans challenges pour sauver
mat alors là ça y est donc elles
reviennent effectivement en option ce
qui n'est pas totalement satisfaisant
mais surtout on a un problème qui reste
entier sait comment est ce qu'on va
faire pour améliorer notre enseignement
des mathématiques en france comment
casser cette machine à créer des
régiments d'élèves qui sont dégoûtés par
la part la matière alors mon point de
vue il s'agit pas du tout de renoncer au
contraire david b6 nous dit une erreur
c'est le signe qu'on peut mieux faire et
d'ailleurs l'écrivain il se contente pas
d'un simple constat dans dans ce livre
il nous donne aussi un chemin qui est
accessible à tous pour découvrir le
plaisir des mathématiques et donc
j'aurai envie si je pouvais de
conseiller au nouveau ministre de
l'éducation nationale la lecture de
mathématiques et revoilà mathématiques à
david b 6,7 au seuil vivement conseillé
à pap ndiaye de la part de delphine
sabattier merci à vous merci les
affranchis c'est la fin de cette
émission se retrouve bien sûr pas demain
demain ce sera clément mérite parce que
moi je vais bosser sur la soirée
électorale soirée documentaire qui
commence maintenant avec jean pierre
gratien ma femme a du crédit sébastien
de belgique sur la surveillance massive
en chine très belle soirée sur lcp
clément mairie comme annette demain soir
[Musique]